teachers. They are the lifeblood of the
flow arts. Whether it be helping newbies
become a lot more comfortable using
props for the first time, helping people
level up at festivals or even creating
online resources to help everybody get
ahead. They are what make our community
tick. And they have a surprisingly
difficult job. And not a lot of people
realize that teaching is in and of
itself a skill that they have to pick
up. So, in this video, I'm going to give
you five tips that will help you improve
as a teacher, regardless of where you
are in that journey.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO, sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm going to
give you my top five best tips for
improving as a teacher. But before we
dive in, let me give a quick shout out
to the friends of the channel. Big
thanks go to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyer Light Toys,
and Ultraoy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible. You can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video. And
just to put a massive thank you out
there to Pekka Beckonin for having
supported this channel for so very long.
I appreciate you and everything that
you've done these past few years. All
right, so from the jump, we do just have
to establish one thing right quick, and
that is that many people mistake
demonstration for teaching. In a lot of
cases, if we can do a particular trick
or technique, we think that simply
showing somebody else the trick or
technique in action is the same thing as
teaching. And it's really not. A
demonstration can inspire somebody and
maybe on their own initiative they will
go ahead and go out and take what
they've seen you do and try to apply it.
But that's not necessarily the same
thing as taking somebody through the
guided process of putting stuff together
for themselves, especially if they're
struggling. So aside from moving beyond
simply demonstrating something, what are
some other ways that we can improve as
teachers? Well, buckle up, friends. Tip
number one, context matters.
So, I have what's going to seem like a
very simple question to ask right off
the bat here, but it's actually way more
complicated than you think.
Why does somebody want to learn this
trick or technique from you? What's
their motivation for doing so? Why
exactly do they think that it is worth
their time to pick this thing up? What
goals does it help them achieve? And
also too, what does it teach them about
the prop in general? See, I think we
tend to focus a little bit too much on
the what and not nearly enough on the
why. And I get why we focus on the what.
You know, those are the words that wind
up in the title of our workshops and the
whole reason that people are coming in
and saying, "I'm going to spend the next
hour with you learning this particular
thing." But we also need to bear in
mind, well, why exactly is this
important to them? Is this a stepping
stone to getting towards a goal? Is it
something that's going to make them more
comfortable with the prop to begin with?
Is it something that they think they're
going to win respect with? We have to
understand where they're coming from in
order to make sure that they walk out of
that workshop satisfied. So, spend a
little bit of time talking with your
students and find out exactly why they
are there. What is it that they're
hoping to get out of it? And how does it
get them closer to their particular
goals? I think once you get to know them
a little bit more as individuals and not
simply as receptacles for whatever trick
they happen to be coming into your class
for, it'll be a lot more helpful both
for you and for them in terms of them
feeling like they're satisfied with what
they got out of the experience.
Tip number two, show don't tell.
So, this kind of goes back to what we
opened the video up on where in simply
demonstrating a trick, I don't think
necessarily is that effective a means of
teaching somebody something. I think
that the more effective way that we go
about teaching anything, be it a
concept, a trick, uh, a whole framework
of thought is to turn it into a story,
is to turn it into kind of a guided
experience that you're taking your
students through. We go from point A to
point B to point C and at each point
it's obvious why we are at that point.
So I had a workshop that I used to teach
back in the day called Fundamentals of
Tech that essentially was tricking
people into learning how to do Xan's
diamond. I would start off by simply
demonstrating linear extensions, but I
wouldn't tell people what they actually
were. We'd start off just moving our
hands back and forth in a straight line
as the PO spun around it and work to
build different shapes out of those
straight lines. Starting with a box,
then a triangle, then an arrow, then an
arrow pointing the other way, and then
we connect the two arrows together. And
oh goodness, that's Xan's diamond. When
exactly did that happen? The great part
about this was not just that I got to
see a bunch of people, some of whom had
literally just picked up a set of poi
for the first time, learn how to do
something that was the hardest PO trick
anybody could do when I first started
up. Even more than that, it was seeing
people go on this journey where they
would gradually increase in confidence
over time. they would feel more
comfortable with the underlying concept
that I was throwing at them. And more to
the point, they would realize that they
had potential that they didn't know
existed before they walked into that
class. And because this built up
incrementally, there was no single step
that felt like it was a bridge too far.
We would do a specific thing and people
would get comfortable with it and then
we would move on to the next step only
when they got super comfortable with the
previous one. And in that way, we could
build up the difficulty of what we were
doing slowly and steadily and still have
people be confident in every step of the
way. So build your workshops as a
progression. Step A, step B, step C, as
many steps as it takes. But take your
students on that journey. Make sure
every step you're asking them to do is
an obvious and not too difficult
progression from what they already know
how to do. And I guarantee you're going
to be surprised by how far you can take
them. Tip number three, never stop
practicing practice. So almost all of
us, especially if we're learning
intermediate or advanced level tricks,
have to go through a progression.
There's step A, step B, step C, step D,
so on and so forth. It's what we were
talking about in the last step here. But
as soon as we get that last step, we get
the final trick, we stop working on all
the steps that led up to it. Cuz after
all, why would you bother continuing to
do those after you've already learned
how to get to the final step, right? And
the answer to this question is that all
those individual steps are really really
important for teaching people how to get
to the final step. If indeed you have
any ambitions of becoming a teacher, you
can never stop practicing those steps
that lead up to the final one. So an
example of this in action, almost
everybody that I know who has learned
the three beat weave learned it via
first learning the two beat weave either
with right-hand leading or left hand
leading and then worked on combining the
two together. Right? That's a pretty
standard way of going about that. Thing
is, as soon as most people get the three
beat weave, they stop practicing the two
beat weave. Because after all, the three
beat weave was the thing we were working
towards all along. So why bother? Well,
the reason why to bother is when you
have to teach the three beat weave to
somebody else, you're probably going to
have to teach them how to do two beat
weaves first. And if you don't remember
how to do those, you're going to be
shocked to discover just how hard they
are to go back and relearn. I cannot
count the number of people I've seen
that get down the three beat weave and
then have to go back to the two beat at
some point either for teaching purposes
or to pick up a different PO trick and
suddenly discover that this thing that
they thought was super simple is no
longer in their wheelhouse and they have
to relearn how to do it. So do yourself
a favor and if you hold any ambitions
about teaching, make sure regardless of
what the trick is that you never stop
practicing those steps that lead up to
it cuz you're going to need to
demonstrate them for somebody else at
some point. and you're going to need to
guide them through there. So, you need
to be super comfortable with them, be
able to talk through them, and be able
to offer feedback as you're doing them,
too. They need to be a second nature to
you as breathing. Tip number four, learn
how to copy not just successes, but also
mistakes. So, this is going to seem
extremely counterintuitive because after
all, the whole point of learning to do a
thing is so you can do the correct
version of it that everybody will love.
So, here's the thing. Most people as
they're learning don't go straight to
the point where they have the thing
down. They go through a twisting,
winding road where this thing goes wrong
or that thing goes wrong and they're
stuck and they have to figure out how to
get through that spot. And the only way
you're going to be able to help them get
through there is if you can duplicate
the mistake that they are making. See,
you can show them the right way to do
it, of course, but if they're struggling
and there's a piece that they're
missing, there's absolutely no amount of
demonstrating the successful thing
that's going to make the dots connect
for them. But if you can copy the
mistake that they are making and compare
it to what you know is the successful
version of that particular trick or
technique, you can guide them through
it. This is an essential step to being
able to help people through the most
difficult part of learning. You have to
put yourselves in their shoes and
experience those mistakes with them.
It's only that way that you can give
them the specific exercises, the
specific changes they need to make that
is going to help them be successful in
the long run. Now, it does need to be
said that this is just a useful skill to
have in general. Not just because it's
helpful for teaching, but also because
it helps you become a better learner as
well. Of course, we all like to fixate
on the cleanest and most perfect version
of a particular trick or technique. But
the thing is, being able to duplicate
anything you see somebody else doing,
whether it is the correct version or
not, is going to mean that you have the
ability to absorb anything that you come
in contact with a lot easier. This is
going to improve your experience, not
just as a teacher, but as a student
yourself. you are going to have such a
level up in terms of your ability to
learn things quickly. So, pick up the
skill. It's an important one. Tip number
five, solicit feedback.
Okay, real talk. If you take only one,
and I mean only one tip from this entire
list, this is the one. And the biggest
reason is you cannot be an effective
teacher without finding out where you
have room for improvement. So this is
what this looks like for me. At the end
of every single workshop I have taught
in the past 12 years, I will pass around
my notebook and a pen and I will ask
everybody to write down their email
addresses. As soon as I am back in the
land of Wi-Fi, I will send each and
every one of them an email that includes
a link to a Google form. That Google
form includes questions about such
things as how was your experience in
class? How was I as a teacher? What were
the most effective aspects of the class?
What were the least effective aspects of
the class? If you could change one thing
about the class, what would it be? And
let me tell you friends, the information
I get from that feedback form is without
a doubt the most valuable information I
have ever received as a teacher. More
valuable than any trick I've ever picked
up. more valuable than any teaching
technique I've ever picked up because
that is a direct conduit into finding
out how best you serve your students.
So, whatever form this happens to take
for you, whether it is a Google form
like mine or something more informal.
And by the way, if you're interested in
that form, I'll include a blank version
of it that you can copy for your own
purposes. Link to that down in the
description. But however you solicit
this feedback, treat it as the most
sacred thing that you will ever touch as
an instructor because it is the route to
becoming not just a good but a great
instructor comes from actively looking
at the areas where you can improve. And
don't get me wrong, it is also good to
feel good about the job that you're
doing and hear about the positive impact
you're having on others. But it is just
as important to find out what and where
you have room for improvement on and to
follow through on it. Awesome. I hope
you enjoyed these tips. Are there any
things that you think make good teachers
that I did not include in this list?
Leave me a comment and let me know what
they might be. And also tell me which of
these tips most hit home for you and
which ones are you going to implement in
your own work. Also, make sure to like,
share, and subscribe to help other
people find this video and of course to
help my channel grow.
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed right
here on screen with me. Thank you all so
much. You rock. And if you are
interested in getting your name in the
credits or access to any other of a host
of awesome rewards that I have available
for my subscribers, then you should go
sign up. Head on over to my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo
and check out what I have to offer. Even
better than that though, you will be
helping me out in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow arts to the whole wide
world. So, go check it out, please and
thank you. And if you'd like some
additional tips on how to structure a
workshop, I will go ahead and include a
link to a video that I did on that very
topic both here on screen as well as
down in the description. Thank you so
much for watching. I hope that you have
an awesome day. Get out and flow. And I
hope that if you get around to teaching
some workshops, they're good ones.
Thanks so much and take care. Peace.